ragazzi non pensavo sinceramente che
forse col sismico e la disneyland di
tokyo ce ne sono due set isner al
normale che c'è anche a parigi c'è al
dente del solo per voi c'è business che
praticamente un disneyland dei
giapponesi
ed è questo se hai
ci siamo ragazzi questa in teoria
dovrebbe essere l'entrata io mi sono già
perso tutto quanto il gruppo perché
stoffa video e quindi i ragazzi sono
andati avanti e non nostra dove cazzo
sono e probabilmente mi perderò qua
[Musica]
no ragazzi voi non potete capire il
video non rende per niente e la cosa più
epica che io abbia mai visto in tutta la
mia vita che cazzo e ho trovato i
ragazzi sentono restiamo nino facendo i
video sordi
aiutato il vulcano qualità
cecchetto il titanic la cosa a grandezza
naturale poi io non la volevo fare la
statua di ci hanno messo quei bastardi
bacio anche freddo piove il lecce
all'ombrello alternativo ma parraga ce
l'abbiamo
[Applauso]
ok ragazzi abbiamo fatto questa cosa
bellissima non avrete capito un cazzo di
quello che è successo ma neanche io ho
capito niente
ora siamo usciti in questo momento e
cioè il titanic davanti a noi è
bellissimo perché ci sono le barche
grosse e le barche grosse più grosse
come questa musica mi fa venire voglia
di farmi venire da diarrea ma donna che
uomo è tutta la [ __ ] giapponese domani
davanti alla porta se sfregiando sasha
fire e questo reggi forte forte l'aria
bravo sasha sei stato bravissimo
esplode il vulcano
andiamo al mare
papà ha detto andiamo a mangiare c'è
anche la piaga b
live
[Musica]
e noi preghiere io voglio capire perché
perché perché
macché chiatarra vestita normale quando
arriva qua perché sa perché ma quanto è
brutto stop esce quanto è brutto
beh che va bene non faceva paura però ci
ho provato papa ci sta portando al
patibolo grazie papà stiamo andando
sotto non so dove
oddio cos'è sta roba da un sottomarino
bellissimo grazie papà che ci porti a
morire così la pamela complico e la roba
lì grazie perché c'è musica della
famiglia taxi che cazzo posso venire con
te papa
ditemi se non è la cosa più dolce che
potesse mai vedere in tutta la nostra
vita
oh mio dio le voglio si comprano minchia
postazione da gaming max in 3d google
maps tutto integrato fantasma
grazie siamo dentro un sottomarino
non ho mai capito che cazzo serve mai
più
forse adesso sarebbe utile capire niente
[Musica]
acqua vera posso pilotare la luce
guardava dati pesci del illumina un
cazzo sembra un gameplay giacché storia
[Musica]
jobs dimmi cosa illuminare i pesci
palatina e vicino ai buchi buy
i bookie ti piace di booking palesemente
serpente
ma che figata ha fatto benissimo e
l'osso papa saraceno cadendo c'è che non
va bene se rosso papa c'è qualcuno
galieni chi è questo ci sono alieni
sott'acqua ragazzi ma chi cazzo è questa
è una gran figata
stiamo emergendo papa siamo usciti e
stato le ripide
io veramente la mia seconda fobia dopo i
ragni e quella dell'acqua cioè
dell'approfondita subacquea stare in un
sottomarino per me è pesante
lo fanno io non safari mai è veramente
enorme perché da sopra non si vede un
cazzo però qua sotto e pieno di merda e
bellissimo abbiamo preso ragazzi tutto
gelato da stop mini chiosco in teoria
dovrebbe essere tipo il biscotto normale
solo che meno è un cazzo di mattone non
vi posso dire quanto è solido cioè
devastante come fai a mangiarlo papa
siamo in pausa ragazzi sono riusciti a
trovare in atto quanto bella stabilità
per niente ci stiamo mangiando questa
specie di coscia di pollo è un cono
gelato alla carne siamo tutti tipo
cavernicoli ea mangiare questa quadra
abbiamo 100 minuti di coda grazie papà
grazie cosa facciamo in questi 90 minuti
con qualcosa troveremo di sicuro
no
[Musica]
ebbene sapete quanto è passato due
minuti
allora sì che hanno trovato il modo
giusto per intrattenersi
ribatte prima private anche uno
allowed
oggi si può credere il cielo i ragazzi
[Applauso]
no
ma che guardiamo
cazzo ma dov'è finito il sole era giorno
prima ma ho paura non si vede un cazzo
regalo e siamo papa paura papà mi sono
piegato addosso papà mi passi un
palloncino papa non vedo un cazzo papa
vi racconti una favola a grazie ha detto
che tuo cugino puzza di merda o stato il
bio ora moriamo
ciao e stato bello ed alla luce è già
finita bene dai grandissimi 90 minuti di
coda per questo reality non si segga
bellissima che cazzo dice non ho visto
niente è tutto buio buio e a caso è 90
minuti ricorda per tutto buio buio pure
fuori ragazzi ma dove cazzo siamo finiti
papa ci hai portato indietro nel tempo
tempio maya un tempo maya maio mai a
papà rapa barbara
barabba fabiana jones barbara il
passaggio alle tute caricato cose ma
no è buono buono per te verde ai piccoli
e tute il telaio del mostro che abbiamo
visto nel cielo regalo telone gallo te
lo regalo di assaggiarlo a me piaceva
questo regalo ecco i piedi
ma cos'è che sono scusato per termoli
carciofo che fa veramente schifo
diego
non c'è il basilisco harry potter sì sì
ma stai calmo
[Risate]
l'incontro harrison ford 6 un figo zio
sam figo come cazzo sempre tutti io e
suri è stato figo è piaciuta
ragazzi questa è la prossima che
facciamo mi faccio solo vedere come si
va fino qua poi e poi si arriva alla
fine quindi dobbiamo invitare tutti i
pop corn siamo io giuseppe che salgono
il fatto è che è buio si è fatto di
legno
sembra che da sempre più veloce di
conserva stato alcuno sembra che vada
più veloce doverla si intensificano e
piove piove diluvia e in più perché
siamo così gialle cazzo questo non lo so
ma ok siamo nella merda resti furono non
è sì questa è fatta di legno ragazzi ci
sei
ma chi colpire nullo madonna 4 alto
marecchia tra i fan e buio eletto papa
il super che però non lo senti questo
ora va pianissimo stare attaccato papa
[Applauso]
ma voglio scendere sera estiqaatsi e
figlioccio rega porca tutta su golf il
magico mondo della disney
anche se ancora non ho visto aladin stig
rancati degli impianti nicchia la
filosofia di questo video è tutta mamma
mia che riprese giapponese tutto quanto
e voi
cheese e bagna cauda ma che ma che noi
ragazzi è stato un grande viaggio ad
inclinando anche se porca [ __ ] stiamo
bloccando tutti insieme spero che vi sia
piaciuto e quindi ragazzi d'occhio vince
per adesso il premio per il miglior
parco mai visto un aspetta solo con
tende con quello di cosenza tipo dell
universal anche quello era spettacolare
quei ragazzi signore vi dicevo sempre
sul momento è un mi piace anche la
pagina di facebook e come nottata la
descrizione si schiera sapevo che non
sarei riuscito a fare la chiusa un mondo
di sci e ci vediamo così un video
bell'anima o di cappella tutti ragazzi
veloce della a tutti i ragazzi ma che
cazzo stampa signora c'è qualche
problema
perfetto